and guns are the leading cause of death
for children and teens in the U.S so
shouldn't helping save the lives of
children be a top priority for you as a
member of the House Majority no it
absolutely should be which is why I say
I would look to the thing that would
absolutely stop this which is putting
armed police officers at every school so
that's a preventive measure that I know
will stop this and there was nothing
like that in these last few mass
shootings there's no armed guards there
so the answer is more guns no the answer
is armed guards right armed guard yes
even more good the kind of guns that
protect the president that protect you
all at CNN is it easy to get into your
headquarters at CNN absolutely not
there's armed guards there there's
single points of Entry I think we should
look at our schools as a place that is
precious uh and and have the same kind
of security that your Corporate Offices
do what kind of security do you have at
CNN headquarters guess what there are
guys with guns there and an awful lot of
them